on july 5th the white house posted this
seemingly uncontroversial and
unremarkable tweet a list of places that
had donated vaccines
it seemed like a banal government press
release few would give much thought to
that is until it was suddenly deleted
and for fear of causing an international
incident no less
see if you can find why
the problem was not the actual donation
nor was it the mere reference to taiwan
a word the u.s government uses all the
time and nowhere in the tweet were the
words country or nation
no the concern was about this tiny flag
which the white house called an honest
mistake
so fragile is this issue that merely
tweeting an icon of a flag might be
interpreted as a change in policy or
even a recognition of statehood
something that could trigger a military
response by china
and yet so too could deleting the tweet
cause confusion
afterward the taiwanese foreign ministry
asked the u.s not to cause unnecessary
speculation after its president and de
facto ambassador were left retweeting a
message now deleted
this was not the first such diplomatic
mishap nor surely will it be the last
the us government practices a strategy
of deliberate ambiguity leading much of
the public many in the media and even a
few politicians to misunderstand its
position
despite what china would have you
believe the us does not in fact adhere
to the one china principle
neither does it support taiwanese
independence though it does have
unofficial relations with its government
the reality is much more complicated
sponsored by morningbrew the free daily
newsletter i read to stay up to date on
the world of tech and business
when mao zedong founded the people's
republic of china in 1949 and promised
to quote liberate taiwan the u.s
initially decided not to intervene
only after the invasion of south korea
in the summer of 1950 did the truman
administration begin recognizing the
strategic value of taiwan
four years later in 1954 the u.s signed
a defense treaty promising to protect
taiwan if attacked
this along with america's refusal to
recognize the prc lasted for another 25
years until it discovered a bigger
threat the soviet union
largely in response to the communists up
north america finally recognized the
people's republic in 1979 as the quote
sole legal government of china
it promised not to pursue a two china's
or one china one taiwan solution which
meant ending official relations with
taiwan
it also stated in a communique the
united states of america acknowledges
the chinese position that there is but
one china and taiwan as part of china
upon hearing this you like many people
might conclude that the u.s acquiesced
to the people's republic
but if so you're not paying close enough
attention
it recognizes the prc as the sole legal
government of china but doesn't define
what china is
remember taiwan is formally known as the
republic of china and both claimed to be
china
on the other hand it merely acknowledges
the chinese position that there is but
one china and taiwan is part of china
the key word here being acknowledge
which is not the same as accept or
recognize
it does however give a similar
impression at least on a cursory reading
and this is certainly no accident the
american position then and now is to
obfuscate to narrowly satisfy china's
stringent demands while giving up as
little as possible in the process
the u.s could argue what fulfilled its
obligations while china could argue the
us fully agreed to its position
a mutually enforced facade of resolution
in reality nothing said or done back in
79 truly resolved the issue both sides
only kicked the can further down the
road and far worse than simply delaying
that ugly conversation the talks created
the superficial illusion of agreement
leading to hurt feelings and accusations
later on
in other words america spoke as vaguely
as possible which china gladly exploited
the chinese translation of the document
for example uses a word closer in
meaning to recognize despite there being
an accurate translation of acknowledge
available
it's quite possible that many in china
and even taiwan most of whom read the
document in chinese believe the u.s
promised more than it actually did
that was after all kind of the point
there's another similar linguistic
misconception
the one china principle is the term for
china's position that taiwan is a part
of the people's republic
this is not the same as generic lower
case one china policies which every
country has a different version of
when china accuses another country of
violating the one china principle it's
really only saying that it disagrees
with the action not that the other
country has broken a promise
make no mistake the u.s does not adhere
to the principle only to its own policy
one which has gone unchanged for over 40
years
now in the process of recognizing the
people's republic the u.s ended its
defense treaty with taiwan replacing it
instead with the taiwan relations act
the tra was designed to reassure taiwan
by providing it with the weapons it
needs to defend itself
and while it states an expectation that
the issue will be resolved peacefully it
does not guarantee military support only
that the president will inform congress
of any potential threat and then take
appropriate action
still all parties operated under the
assumption of eventual unification
all that changed in the 90s as taiwan
transitioned from brutal authoritarian
rule to what is today one of the
strongest and most vibrant democracies
on earth
the process was neither smooth nor easy
and made advocating for independence
legal complicating the situation
today the future status of taiwan is
still the primary issue that divides
parties
on one side are the blues who favor
closer economic ties to china
china buys nearly half of taiwan's
exports which they see as a critical
relationship to maintain to them china
is less an adversary and more a business
partner
the dominant party in this camp is the
kuomintang or kmt
on the other side are the greens led by
the democratic progressive party dpp
greens see trade with china as a
dangerous dependency that leads to
economic coercion
they prefer the term taiwan to the
republic of china
but while the kmt is sometimes sloppily
labeled pro unification and the dpp pro
independence this is simply not true
in reality both sides agree that
maintaining the status quo is the best
short to medium term strategy and
neither side except for a few radicals
advocates unification or independence
the greens argue taiwan is already an
independent sovereign state and thus has
no reason to declare independence
something which would surely start a war
none of this is meant to discount the
ferocity of taiwanese politics healthy
democracy is fierce and messy but to
highlight how subtle their differences
this graph helps put things in
perspective
when asked their preferences the
taiwanese public has answered remarkably
consistently for 20 years
the top three responses are all maintain
the status quo and only differ in the
long term
28 percent prefer to decide at a later
date 27 percent wish to maintain the
status quo indefinitely and one quarter
wish to maintain the status quo but move
toward independence
only a small minority wish to unify
immediately move toward unification or
declare independence as soon as possible
ironically it's most often americans
halfway across the globe who panic when
china flies fighter jets through
taiwanese airspace not the taiwanese
public for whom such shows of
intimidation have become mundane
most are content simply keeping things
as they are
as is the united states
officially it does not support
independence but remember american
diplomats are precise in their meaning
the u.s does not say it opposes
independence which would mean taking a
position
but while it does not take a stance on
the outcome it does advocate for the
process not only does it oppose a
forceful unification by china so too
does it oppose a unilateral declaration
of independence by taiwan something that
would also destabilize the region when
taiwan's president proposed a public
referendum on independence in 2003 the
u.s was caught between a rock and a hard
place
on one hand it did not support what it
perceived as dangerous antagonizing
on the other it did not want to publicly
oppose a legal democratic process
instead it reiterated indirectly but
unequivocally that it did not support
independence sending the message that
the president had crossed a line since
then taiwanese officials have gone out
of their way to prove they don't plan on
rocking the boat
in 2018 current president tsai ing wen
stayed silent on a referendum calling
for its olympic name to be changed from
chinese taipei to taiwan
and she's in the green camp
every major politician today understands
the need to proceed with caution
repeating sometimes monotonously that
they won't pursue
independence that doesn't stop china
from claiming they support independence
however which engenders nationalism at
home and helps narrow the boundaries of
what's acceptable
but things can't continue like this
forever
while america and taiwan support the
status quo for now everyone agrees it's
untenable in the long term
one of the three red lines china says
the crossing of which would trigger an
attack is if taiwan refuses to ever
consider negotiating unification
the possibility of change however
minuscule is thus imperative to
maintaining the peaceful status quo
the question is in what direction does
time favor in terms of public opinion
the answer is clear when broken down by
age it's evident that younger
generations feel an increasingly strong
taiwanese identity distinct from china
the 2014 sunflower movement demonstrated
how determined young people are which
recent developments in hong kong will
surely only convince them of more so
and yet every day china's military and
economy grow stronger it may believe
time is on its side that the balance of
power will only shift in its favor
likewise does it surely notice america's
growing disinterest in acting as the
world's police force china may doubt the
will of americans to fight a war so
distant at a time when it's so
preoccupied at home
in the meantime taiwan is stuck in a
historically unprecedented limbo
a weird in-between state in which it can
enjoy freedom only if it pretends not to
a status quo that has somehow survived
eight american administrations 40 years
and yet can suddenly be called into
question with a mere icon of a flag in a
tweet
you may wonder where i find the ideas
for these videos instead of reading
traditional news which is too often dry
sensationalist and irrelevant i try to
consume less but higher quality news and
today's sponsor morningbrew is one of
the few sources i've read every single
day now for about six months long before
they started sponsoring the channel
morningbrew is a daily newsletter that
covers topics like tech business and
finance in other words it's kind of the
perfect fit for anyone who enjoys these
videos
i find it's a good way of staying up to
date on a wide cross-section of
different topics one edition may feature
a concise summary of the most important
news story of the day followed by some
fascinating statistics and a few links
to the best articles videos or tweets of
the week
best of all morning brew is completely
100 percent free there's no trial or
premium upgrade just a concise daily
newsletter delivered to your inbox each
morning you can sign up in about 15
seconds just by clicking the button you
see on screen now